[Música]
venezuela se prepara para las elecciones
locales del próximo 21 de noviembre a
estos comicios regionales están llamados
a votar más de 21 millones de personas
para elegir 3 mil 82 cargos de mandato
popular más de 70 partidos de
movimientos políticos ya comenzaron sus
campañas para las que están inscritos
unos 70 mil candidatos de todas las
tendencias políticas estas elecciones se
celebran en un ambiente de pandemia y
además tras la ruptura de los diálogos
entre el oficialismo y la oposición que
se estaban desarrollando en la ciudad de
mexico
esto tras la extradición de alexa up a
eeuu cuando el gobierno del presidente
nicolás maduro dijo no más y se
levantaron entonces de esta mesa de
diálogos quiero saludar a nuestro
segundo invitado del día de hoy roberto
y con el rector principal del s en el
consejo nacional electoral de venezuela
desde el 4 de mayo de este 2021 a massa
miembro de la junta nacional electoral
rector gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
primero quiero empezar preguntarle es
como llega el país a estas elecciones
del 21 de noviembre
bueno llega a partir del cronograma
electoral
digamos constitucional que implica que
cada cierto tiempo cada cuatro años en
casos las gobernaciones se renuevan las
autoridades regionales
y las municipales y pues eso tenía que
hacerse este año y pues dentro del
dentro del cronograma electoral normal
pues eso es lo que tenía que ocurrir
pero también ocurre dentro de un
ambiente donde desde el año 2017 una
parte importante de los actores
políticos de oposición no ha venido
participando
y
también ocurre dentro de la renovación
reciente del consejo nacional electoral
con su directorio pues nombrado el
último 4 de mayo entonces pues una serie
de situaciones que estamos tratando de
revertir si la participación electoral
en venezuela ha venido bajando del 75
por ciento en el 2015 a sólo el 30 por
ciento de estas últimas elecciones del 6
de diciembre 2020 y bueno nuestra tarea
es producir condiciones que
objetivamente sean mejores y que logren
participen más actores políticos y
también mayor cantidad de ciudadanos eso
le quería decir el rector picón porque
cómo está entonces la confianza de los
venezolanos en este órgano el consejo
nacional electoral que por mucho tiempo
estuvo digamos relacionado tilda va a
estar en pues del lado de él entonces el
presidente hugo chávez y de nicolás
maduro como van a hacer ustedes como
ente nacional electoral para poder
revertir esto y darle una nueva imagen a
un consejo nacional electoral que por
muchos años estuvo digamos señalado de
estar un poco parcializado
bueno hemos estado construyendo
condiciones técnicas y políticas en
cuanto a la política
digamos se habilitaron
organizaciones con fines políticos que
han permitido que los actores que no
habían participado en 2017 lo estén
haciendo ahora en buena medida se trata
de la tarjeta de la mesa la unidad
democrática que pues ha permitido que
estos actores se postulen en todos los
estados del país
por otra parte también la invitación a
instituciones internacionales
reconocidas por todos para que sean
observadores o envíen misiones
técnicas a venezuela es un tema
importante ya están desplegándose en
venezuela la unión europea el centro
carter y también naciones unidas con un
equipo técnico y pues eso pues da
mayores garantías a todos los actores de
que las elecciones van a ser reportadas
en todas sus dimensiones por entes
independientes que todos reconocemos
como y finalmente pues las condiciones
técnicas que se han estado adelantando y
que garantizan que los votos se cuentan
correctamente y que los electores que
participan son los únicos que emiten
votos si eso le quería preguntar rector
como ustedes trabajan junto con los
observadores internacionales digamos un
caso específico de la unión europea
bueno hemos tenido varias reuniones
digamos donde la unión europea nos ha
pedido información sobre el proceso
electoral sobre la organización del
proceso la organización interna del cn y
bueno con esa información ellos han
realizado un plan de observación
este ya están desplegados en todo el
país evaluando la campaña electoral
evaluando en la preparación de los
actores políticos y el cine para el día
de la elección que el 21 de noviembre
ahorita hay 44 equipos pero han 22
equipos distribuidos en todo el país
+ 11 técnicos en caracas que están
haciendo observación a nivel central y
los próximos días llegarán 32 más que
los complementarán
como ustedes reciben esto digamos estas
organizaciones
internacionales porque recordemos que la
unión europea como muchos otros países
occidentales pues no reconocían de
alguna manera el gobierno ante el
presidente nicolás maduro esto sería o
lo tomarían a lo mejor como un
reconocimiento internacional al gobierno
del presidente nicolás maduro y dejando
a un lado un poco
el reconocimiento de juan guaidó como el
presidente de venezuela cuando lo
hicieron en su momento
yo creo que no tiene que ver con eso
sino con el
apoyo a reestablecer la ruta electoral
como mecanismo de cambio dentro de la
constitución que puede hacer aceptado
por todas las partes y en ese sentido
es un proceso eso
digamos no coyuntural de esta elección
sino que se intenta que éste sea un
proceso de acompañamiento técnico de
largo plazo que nos ayude a reconstituir
el voto como instrumento de cambio y
reconocimiento entre los actores rector
son 21 millones de venezolanos los que
están llamados a las urnas pero teniendo
en cuenta también la migración
venezolana millones de venezolanos
afuera cuántas personas ustedes se creen
que podrían participar en esta elección
bueno fíjense técnicamente
en de acuerdo registro electoral la
participación fue del 30 por ciento de
las últimas elecciones del 6 de
diciembre
pero si uno hace una encuesta en
venezuela más o menos el 40 por ciento
dice que participó porque el denominador
es más pequeño es decir aunque el
registro tiene 21 millones los que
pueden votar que están en venezuela son
17 millones quizás un poquito menos
entonces este estamos hablando de que
votó el 40 por ciento de esos 16
millones y largos y no el perdón el 30%
el 40 por ciento de esos 30 millones de
largos y no el 30 por ciento de 91
ahorita eso pudiera subir un poco porque
hay más actores políticos y hay algo más
de confianza en sn a partir de estas
garantías que hemos establecido
yo pienso que si el año pasado
participaron 6 millones de lectores
para elegir la asamblea nacional en este
año pudiéramos estar teniendo alrededor
de 88 y medio quizás ok y eso pues va a
ser a un proceso progresivo de
reconstrucción de comunidad de confianza
en las instituciones